hello everyone so welcome to another
episode of unlocking lily that's always
been my dream to be a speaker which led
me to quit my day job to work and mentor
under Evan full time and all of you are
coming along to the ride with me in
every episode I pick on a different
challenge to really help me grow as a
speaker so in this video I'm going to be
bringing all of you behind the scenes in
my mentoring sessions with Evan because
I learned from Tony Robbins the success
of leaves clues I actually have a
surprise for you I'm going to go find
him and we're going to answer some
questions together I'm actually really
looking forward to this because I don't
even know what he's going to say so hope
you guys enjoy it help you very soon
so I finally got to Evans building I'm
going to go stairs and record the video
for you guys I'm actually excited to
find out his answers to a lot of things
because she don't know it against her
sellable seat we'll see how it goes of
good be fun what do we do it Lilly
what's happening look at the who did
this Evan how did we meet Evan how do we
meet yeah
so Lily started at a chocolate salsa I
didn't own at the time just an investor
in the school and an instructor and then
you were a student level 6 class I was
your student was the first time we met
they might all remember when I first met
you neither us remember how we met but
it was dancing I chose a salsa and then
and then you left to go to another
school to perform yes and then you came
back yeah to teach yet and then we
didn't really do we I don't know I mean
I'm sure we've danced and had pictures
of that nothing not not matter what
either of us okay and then we had our
first meetings which was apparently
memorable for you but not for me I
bought the entire business turning us
off the last year in January and Lilly
was one of our salsa instructors one of
the things that was important to me is I
like seeing attention to people on my
team and knowing who they are and what
their ambitions are what their dreams
are how it could help and also just
outside of just work you know for most
of the instructors TDS is a part-time
gig they have full-time jobs or their
own business and then at night they're
teaching because that's when our classes
are and if I can help them along their
journey and just better understand them
those my goal and also I was inheriting
a team you know I didn't build this team
so I was inheriting the people who are
on this team apart from Alex so I kind
of picked to help me run it but
everybody else was already on it and was
hoping to have mean I new faces and we
know said hi and had some dances that
was I was not remember about memorable
but the thing so so remember we met at
just above the studio there's a movie
theater and we had a table this is
random table
data it's kind of weird that you and we
chatted for like two hours or maybe more
a little more good morn three hours
three hours anyway to think that I'm
fetching about Lilly was I loved I just
love to survive I love her attitude
I love the hard-working this and and I
think I said something like at some
point we're going to work together on
something I think it's a time you're
also you didn't know what you wanted to
do and it was you know I don't know that
you saw yourself as an entrepreneur but
never but like never never did I see
myself at that right I don't know
I saw greatness within and I and I said
just keep you posted what you're doing
other ideas if I can play a part
I'd love to something like that without
even knowing what you were interested in
because you're still trying to figure
that stuff out I think I walked away
feeling like I could do more what's the
next question we go the next one this
one was our second meeting which is a
big deal for me but not a big deal for
you okay there we go
you audited one of my classes oh so
another thing that I introduced was
meeting who was auditing classes so
going to a class and just seeing how the
instructor is doing traditionally would
be your set up as instructor and then
you never get a visit and you never get
any feedback on what you're doing to
improve so I was dying for feedback okay
I wanted to know okay I wanted I wanted
to get better as an instructor and I
didn't get any direction with the
exception of maybe my just my scores
right but that didn't really tell me how
to get better jazz I told me that I sat
at a certain standard that's it and you
sat through one of my classes and we
then after that we sat down I think you
I think he told me a lot of things I was
doing right okay I don't think you ever
said that you're doing this wrong and
like I there was a lot of great things I
was doing okay that's one thing okay
that's all you remember that's all I
remember I got just one thing the one
negative thing one negative is I feel
like I don't know you and I thought
I have known you for six years okay and
that were really really bothered me and
at first I was really offended I think
well you know he doesn't know me because
he does you didn't put the effort to get
to know me I'm pretty awesome
no was the context of the class you were
saying that I don't you're not relatable
to the students in that's in class okay
nothing class okay okay so and then you
said to me they will learn from you more
if you're more relatable and they feel
like they know you
right okay and I couldn't figure out why
that was a problem
I can't even okay I don't understand why
relatability was such an issue okay
isn't it good not to be relatable okay
isn't good to be an inspiration okay so
that's what our thinking at the time and
then it's simple while I think if I took
a few weeks or even months to realize
what was actually going on okay and then
it just but it's that with me though
like I was exceeding inside for a long
time and then I kind of realized you
know why why am i unrelatable I try to
put myself in a very um on a platform
and I try to be very perfect but that's
because I'm too afraid to actually show
what's actually going on inside okay and
that's where all the all the
vulnerability stuff started coming in
after researching why and then I started
reading about vulnerability listening to
Bernie around talk and it's just like
that there and that's me I want to be
perfect and perfection doesn't exist
because I'm too afraid to do something
that is vulnerable that was the start
and that was a start of everything I was
in the process of writing the book and
on TDS is in the book is built around
family and I was working with Alex in
getting him to figure out his one word
and do all that was such a battle at the
beginning and I briefly mentioned it to
you in one of the conversations and for
some reason it stuck you don't hit you
at the right time or whatever and then
you jumped on it and you went with
integrity at the time yeah because of
what you're dealing with I think part of
me trying to search for personal
development all of
about searching for me I wanted more
meaning in my life yeah and you just
kind of ascended with this idea Wow I
could find my purpose and I think I was
just ready
I was ready - yeah you jumped on it
really quickly and I jumped on it really
quick oh yeah yeah because I know but I
was focused on what was going on at the
time so yeah I took the wrong words and
then so that was another you know like
oh this is it's great how quickly lily
is moving on these things but it was
great to see her taking the feedback
finding the one word super quick just
makes it easier when you understand what
the person's makeup is easy to do
everything with them and then I finished
their manuscript I give the thirty
people local people who was a huge
double double the size of this book and
you had some good feedback in there and
it was reading the book with Conte to
change the word because before dozens or
you sent to an exercise I think we just
talked about it and you came up with
integrity yeah we talked about it and
then what was reading the book was I
think it's not anyone pages ok maybe
like one just the edge of the I'm sorry
and I came up with integrity
and then I read the book or the
manuscript at the time and then I the
the second award extraordinary came out
of a place where I was very
uncomfortable with integrity and it was
uncomfortable sharing stories around it
okay because it just didn't feel like
like right I did not know like I didn't
not know how to articulate my other word
but I just knew integrity was not like
we had a meeting what was a meeting was
opposed because I was concerned about my
one word so I had a meeting with you
okay okay okay and then I know what
happened after that meeting and the
night we kind of worked through it and
then I went to bed that day went to bed
that night
okay well God's protection than I
realized that's just for extraordinary
because I started thinking about all the
daydreams I like to have as a little
girl somewhere along the way Lily told
me that she went to be a speaker that
was your dream to be a speaker you sized
up onstage you didn't know what your
message was a baby
oh yeah I remember I don't remember what
it was I remember
conversation and then you said you said
these words which was really interesting
it was good you guys don't tell me what
your vision is because it might just
come true that's true that's good yeah
do you remember what your first
expressive was yeah well it was um I did
a few of them
I think the first it was how to love
yourself so I mean I have a youtube
channel there's an opportunity to I want
to be a speaker let's do it come on
board be guest on occasion had guests
come on and be a part of the videos
Alice has been on a number of times more
about him being a thought leader and
getting his skills up there but he
doesn't have ambitions to be a speaker
so yeah you told me your goal and we
started to make it happen where did you
want to slash my car tires like I know
I'm not I really said you said you sent
me a note about flashing no bunch of
liars I gave her the exercise of writing
her credo in her bio so what's the funny
one word you find you Creed you're funky
right nitrate your bio helps to kind of
set your path and then she wrote it
somewhere in the bio she wrote I want to
I'm going to slash Evans Vespa tires as
a test to see if I would have ID if I
actually read it or not I do my work I
read it you read it they wrote it I knew
it though it was a test so I was looking
for ways to again help Lily on her path
to be a speaker so the YouTube Buddhist
was a start then Lily you know said okay
how about we we were on a workshop I
thought it's not what were kind of known
for we don't do personal development
workshops but we have a studio space we
have students even if only couple people
show up how but we do a workshop talking
about extraordinary creating
extraordinary lives and you came in and
did that and we met a couple times to go
over the content I remember that
remember the first session we had
downstairs at Loblaws going over the
feedback oh yeah I kind of totally
changed yeah directional because I to
that point I only tested it on my
husband and it worked and then when I
when I gave you the workshop it didn't
make sense so I end up going back and
scrapping everything in which took me a
hundred hours to make to begin with
and then I went back and that week I
completely changed it and then I
delivered it that a week later
so we met like a week before to go over
the content and answer questions and
these nerds and I think the biggest
challenge was you you created a work
Chevron an extraordinary life for what
extraordinary means to you but not
allowing that means of my own Grace and
we want to allow them to define what it
means for them that was different I
think it's the biggest difference of
yeah and then we ran their workshop in
it and it was good those 10 people
showed up to the first one yes look like
them good people enjoyed it good
feedback and then from there we talked
about having potential one word
workshops so hey people have asked me to
do workshops I don't I don't want to
really do workshops but does an
opportunity you could do it we're also
thinking about implementing more within
TDS culture at the time and so having
really do regular workshops from the
studio we had a discussion member before
saying like listen this has to be
something you fully believe in and
understand and I get it is my message
you has to be your message to it's okay
to have your own spin on it and your own
take on it and you know Lilly delivers
it a way that I think slightly this is
what I would do but you have to believe
in what's in the book and not be you
know not be teaching something that you
don't pull hardly believe in and then
you took a couple days yeah I know if
you read the book again yay let's make
the audio version or I read the first
version oh wow I read a book a couple of
times right at that point I was actually
really proud of myself that I took a
couple of days wait wasn't the first
book that you've read in like 20 years
in something 20 acts yes I was really
proud of myself for doing that because
originally I would have just had yet at
that moment I was almost sure I was
almost sure that I was going to do it
Rick but I really wanted to make sure is
if it's a mission that I want to I want
to be part of I wanted to see that I
have a few few days and I realized that
we're very similar it's very important
to know what you stand for
in order to do things so I jumped on a
mission and then I did the workshops
after the workshop I saw
to a Facebook message thing that thank
you for giving me the opportunity okay
and then you wrote back and say I have
an idea for you and then I got so
excited I had a meeting that night okay
then I kind of put off I knew something
great was doing oh I knew I know
something I just had a feeling I like I
like telling people have buy an idea for
them and then and then let them sit on
that for a day or two and then issue up
no I can't leave getting on it would
never curiosity never part of the part
of the process
never so I think I was just impressed
with the workshop I was at the workshop
I didn't I didn't say anything people
got a free copy of the book and I signed
autographs and answer question at the
end but throughout the workshop Lilly
handled everything and it's intimidating
to first like it's a that was a bigger
roubo like 30-something people I'm there
to write so like 30,000 people I'm there
you know the off of the book yeah I can
imagine it's intimidating the recent net
presenting somebody else's material and
then there were some tough questions to
which would she did a great job
answering and she could have easily
deferred it to me like well Evan what do
you think and and she just chose to
answer it which is great that impressed
me one great thing about Lilly she o is
if it's going to make her feel
uncomfortable that she wants to go up
and do it so jump into that maybe truly
uncomfortable so I have to go ahead and
do it default mindset which is good we
met and I had this idea that that to try
to turn Lilly into a speaker and make it
a business and leave her job you had you
had changed your job like a year ago
seeing some funny government years ago
something like that like I moved around
and I was actually when you approached
me I was at a job that I was pretty
content with I was content and I didn't
hate it when I actually liked it so
that's when you approached me yeah
and so the it is to turn it into a
business
turn Lilly Lilly model speaker into a
business it was one of those heart
decisions for me because at the time I
mean I have my youtube channel I had my
main business takes up a ton of
my time at TBS which we're so growing
and still lots to do is still more
mentorship for Alex before we get to the
point where we need to be so like time
is crunched don't have the time for this
but it's just this is the timing it
feels right I'm gonna go I actually
didn't think you were gonna say yes
surprise Leah knowing I would have put
it like 35 percent really I would have
said 35 percent but at least not yet not
on the spot
like maybe okay let me think of what you
know maybe in a six month a year or
something and so that was that was what
I was expecting kind of going in but you
know what putting on the grade I don't
see what happens and and it but then I
stepped in with you know she said yes
and it's great let's do it so it wasn't
there was no regret or anything there
but that yeah I was a little off in the
percentage sir
interesting no it's good I was not
injured potential now looking back in
retrospect was probably like one of the
easiest decisions I have to make and the
rest I would have figured out was like
the finances everything else I could
have figured out I think that was the
biggest thing that was holding me back
was those financial parts I've always
been such a secure person and always had
a safe job but but I knew my heart I
knew there's something there's something
gonna happen that money and when you
showed up and when use I really knew I
had a feeling that's not like no just
come just come tonight
so when Evan proposes idea to me I had
the choice of working remotely if I
wanted to I think it was I am most days
most days if I if I wanted to except for
our days when we meet together but I
decided that I wanted to be around Evan
as much as possible and the reason for
that is then not only I think there's
like a certain aura about you
awesome Polly hammered white look at
that look at that crazy there's a
certain aura about Evan and then the
other thing is done I like being earshot
away from you and seeing how you handle
things and deal with things and how you
thought processes and and some of your
confidence to just starting out I'm just
I'm just beginning I sometimes I don't
believe in my
else as much as you believe in me and
having the confidence behind it helps
too
so we initially set out that Wednesdays
we're going to be Lille days and so we
spend Wednesday's meeting going over
notes planning reviewing videos talking
strategy preparing for speeches that
kind of stuff and then the other days is
always as always I mean I have something
that I do every single day
so Mondays TBS Dane Tuesday's my youtube
channel ting and Wednesdays literally
dating Thursdays and evening day but
there's micro moments in between on the
other days that leads the conversations
so I also took I took Alex Lily and
Edwin and Nina to Tony Robbins in LA and
we can exclude them down we stayed at
Airbnb and we got tickets to see Tony's
unleash the power then yes that was a
stylist to recognize the people who had
done the one word exercise and Alex was
heavily into it because I was meeting
with him daily and he was living and
breathing it Lilian Edwin Edwin is a
assistant instructor right now training
with lily and I had one conversation
with him when he kind of jumped on on it
as well similar to you and so I can
reward these guys we can go down and
have some fun
and come back so that was that was good
sharing the five of us share the house
for a bit this is different what do you
guys want to know leave it in the
comments so I think one you want to work
at a place where you're going to learn
something so you want to work at a place
where you're going to you're going to
get the skills get the knowledge that
the experience that you want to become I
think I think with this you just kind of
flipped into it you know you're like you
are at TDS you are teaching you want to
do something else is a different owner I
just happen to be in the space that you
wanted to get into right so that was
that was a lucky break every time you
get any kind of opportunity you just
deliver 110 percent you just do it
better than everybody else and it's the
same thing in business aiming for your
customers like why so I'm going to pick
you over somebody else because you just
put in
more work always over deliver on the
expectations right like do way more than
what was asked of you
and you're going to get asked to come
back and sometimes that means you'll
work with people who won't appreciate
that value and you don't get the results
but if you keep doing that if you bring
an attitude of over delivering into
every relationship that you come across
yes some people take advantage yes some
people will recognize a value yes some
people won't be able to afford your
value but if you keep doing that to
everybody to become in contact with
eventually you'll start to move out of
your environment to much better one
where the answer is not to just be
cynical and said nobody ever preachments
on value so I'm going to always play
small for those two my life also like
doing something just based on getting
the appreciation to you and you have to
genuinely love and what you're doing I
mean in the comments help like every I
appreciate I appreciate everything that
comes my way
but if I just did it for positive
feedback I don't think I would last that
long because it will turn negative
sometimes it will be negative and I
would walk away I've been fairly look
very very lucky though yeah you've got
the good bands like your nominative it
again superfans
yeah I've been very lucky really want
some haters guys I think it's such a
shame that's a wrap up leave Lily wrap
up Q the lily wrap up right now so I'm
back filming with Evan I hope you
enjoyed that little bit of like insight
look in my mentoring sessions with him
so I thought I'd share three things that
I really love about working with Evan
the number one thing is that he has a
genuine care in finding out what I want
to do and what my goals are and he tries
to find opportunities for me to grow but
the same time when I do make mistakes or
I don't work as hard as I should he
holds me accountable which is not
pleasant for me but it's absolutely
necessary to help me grow in my case I'm
always trying to look for ways to help
the people
my team and what their their goals and
their ambitions are I think being up
front and letting people know like new
things you want to work on I mean you
had a place where you're going to learn
and you're going to improve or you're at
a place that you're just going to make
money from and so if you're at a place
where if you tell your boss that you
want to improve when you want to work on
these new things and can I learn and
even in my own time can I work on some
projects and they say no and it's
consistent like is that a place that you
want to stay out of nah that's just a
paycheck where you want to go somewhere
they have to provide value you know if
Lily came on camera for my video then
sucked and said really bad things in
much pretty close okay I wasn't the rain
you know um yeah she wouldn't be invited
back it was totally fine it wasn't a
solo I asked Lily from Corona Delta to
join me on this video the last time we
film was pretty good a time before both
her and Alex didn't have their lines
ready for like why are you telling me
yeah because I was hardly guys this is
an opportunity for you recording videos
with you takes Cristina and me four to
five times longer so you have to come
with your line prepares like I don't
need to tell you how to do it you know
believe with the hand so there give me
some tough love to write but like they
need to have that stuff down you have to
know what you're doing and then the
second thing that I really love about
working with Evan is he gives me tons
and tons and tons of feedback so every
Wednesday he and I meet where I could
get him caught up with my progress as
well as we review my unlocking Lily's
videos together we watch it painfully
from me really painful to watch those
videos over and over again but he gives
me tons of tips and ideas and
suggestions where I can not only make
the videos better but become a more
compelling speaker way more comfortable
in front of the camera compared to when
you were starting it personally if we go
back and watch the first one the ongoing
challenge to still stretch yourself on
all these videos is still to feel the
words that you're saying like I don't
feel grow as you're saying grow
you're being professional and great and
warm and not not cold because it's warm
but you're not actually feeling the
words you're saying you're just saying
them in a really more up anyway also
another thing that I do is now they
mentioned I'm like how does glow look
like on camera that's that's why I think
whatever helps you let me try it it
doesn't help me right so there's not
working another house I'm going to give
that sometimes everything that it's not
working I think especially with our
movements you want to let them come more
naturally so if you're feeling grow your
hands will just do yeah which I said I'm
like bro right right yeah and some
people need to some people go too crazy
on their hands and like the hands become
distracting to the point and some people
are like robotic and you need to like
okay like yeah breathe them some people
just more naturally expressive than
others which is okay you're explaining
it the thing is you're summarizing what
you're doing and you do it in a
fantastic warm way you're summarizing
really well but you not just feel what
you're saying that's the difference in
make sense yeah it is it ongoing sure
that I were to have a conversation with
someone how that like s how you wouldn't
be like that yeah challenge to grow or
whatever however grow feels like if
you're scary in the moment alert yeah
then instead of me worrying about like
that doesn't look like work a lot of it
will come to with repetition and
practice it's really just being the
advice of being natural which is hard
right so it comes with practice more
practice it'll lead to better results
right and number three which is probably
the most important one he loved to make
fun of me and it's much needed because
I'm on this trajectory and I really want
to grow and achieve things and sometimes
I could be a little bit intense and
inside my own head so he lines up the
mood by poking fun at are the things I'm
doing in the videos was a super fun and
it kind of puts me at ease and makes my
environment a lot of fun to work in but
see a little bit of that I see the next
look at the next and that can go in
there and be courageous
see that to the little part in one there
and equation another one there
use the civilize it's my star were
coming out mmm
well good I want to see our that I bro
right like the neck let's that's the
kind of thing like nobody will notice it
what they'll feel it right like why is
she so like I'm feeling yeah I'm good
I don't know like that I'll do what very
clearly Lily so for my next challenge
I'm going to be filming in public I'm
Yonge and Dundas Square because I learn
from brené Brown that I need to have the
courage to show up so that's next week
and I really hope I have the courage to
show up so wish me luck and I hope it
all goes well so the question of the day
is do you have one question that Evan
and I did not cover in our video please
write in the comments below and I'll try
my best to answer that question for you
so thank you so much for watching guys I
actually have a special shout out for
Millville Millville Rose whenever you
feel awkward filming in public or if you
hear a negative comment please remember
this quote haters gonna hate
potatoes going to tape and now you're
ready good luck so I have no idea what
potatoes going to potat means but when I
saw it I thought it was like the
funniest thing in the world so Melville
thank you so much every time I see this
it makes me laugh it makes me feel so
much better
any time I come across any haters which
I don't but if I do I could always think
about this anyways um guys I don't know
what else to say thank you so much for
all the comments the heartfelt one as
well as the really funny ones are so so
appreciated so thank you so much and
I'll see you guys very very soon
you